people ask me all the time you know what
what do you think it is you know yeah
what is it really and we're just not
there we're not at a point where we can
necessarily draw conclusions on it now
you you've you've said it could be ours
it could be someone else's on this
planet or or it could be something else
that we haven't identified that is
either from here from somewhere else the
end of the day for me this is very
simple it's either a national security
Aviation safety issue and we need to
deal with that with the mechanisms we
have or it's something else and we need
to have the scientific integrity and The
Bravery to go look at it and explore it
regardless of the results
[Music]
thank you
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast former Navy fighter pilot
engineer by training and now founder of
Americans for safer Aerospace Ryan
Graves welcome Ryan hey Andrew thanks
for having me here thank you for being
here so we're we're going to talk about
your work around uh unidentified aerial
phenomena uh and uh the fact that you
are now trying to mainstream a case that
I think a lot of Americans are highly
interested in but as a former Navy
fighter pilot how realistic was top gun
Maverick and where does shirtless Beach
football rank in terms of the bonding
activities necessary to build a strong
team
I'll say hi to quite high on the last
point there
you know the rest was classified uh but
you know the movie was pretty realistic
and in fact
um I know some of the the active duty
Navy Pilots that flew a lot of those
those filming missions if if you will
and a lot of the um the tactics that we
see executed in there are based off of
real Mission parameters uh having a
pre-planned strike and ingressing in a
high threat scenario and so it was very
very realistic and I know Top Gun played
a hand in recommending some of the uh
the action scenes and the shots uh
whether we're always that close and
whatnot maybe Up For Debate but it was
certainly good good movie good filming
great so how many years were you a
fighter problem when you were an
instructor yourself right
that's correct I spent a total of about
11 years in the Navy which is
essentially uh one cycle for a pilot
especially as a fighter pilot because we
have eight years after our training
which is about three years makes you
sound like a doctor man in a good way
you're like a pretty badass it's like a
PhD in flying in a sense we um you know
we go to that three and a half years of
training and we officially get winged
but then we go out to the fleet and once
we get to the fleet we really begin the
real training where we learn the real
tactics and how to actually employ them
with the weapon systems integrating that
into a team combat environment and then
eventually into the the aircraft carrier
combat environment as well and off we go
into a deployment so you know we've
really never stopped training or
exceeding in that career field and even
after we finish our deployments we come
back to get training for a large four
strike commander and things of that
nature so
to continuous training and learning
environment for sure and and you flew
how many missions in the Middle East I I
didn't count them to be honest but I did
fly uh more than I have counted right
now between operation inherent resolve
and operation enduring Freedom uh those
are the operations we've had in
Afghanistan as well as in the Iraq Syria
area when all the Isis work was kicking
off well thank you for your service to
the country thank you for risking your
life uh and thank you now for the case
that you're making which again
um I was joking with you before we
started the interview that when I was
running for president I told the
American people I would come clean about
Area 51 and whatever the government knew
about
extraterrestrials so you encountered
unidentified aerial phenomena at various
points during your military career
certainly so after our my first combat
deployment when we came back we upgraded
our Radars from the APG 73 to the 79
radar just a much better radar can see
more things and we started noticing
things that we weren't seeing just
earlier in the day with the other radar
and what we were seeing were just radar
contacts that we weren't expecting they
were typically stationary
0.0 Mach and that's stationary in the
Stream if you will of the air and so
we're not expecting anything to be
stationary up there unless it's Tethered
to the ground and even then it would be
bouncing around
but these would typically be stationary
when they were not stationary they'd
travel about 0.6 to 0.8 Mach which is
upwards of about 350 knots uh any other
circular patterns or race track patterns
or just heading out east over the ocean
eventually we got close enough where all
our sensors inside of our jet they
essentially slew to whatever our radar
is looking at at this time we just
thought there were radar malfunctions
not physical objects that could uh hurt
our aircraft yet sure but eventually we
got close enough with our sensor systems
to actually make out the IR energy the
infrared energy that was coming off of
the the objects and so at this point we
had to respect that you know there was
physically something at that piece of
the sky and to you know avoid it the
best we could of course you know there
was a investigatory period where people
said hey let's go take a look with their
eyeballs and and see what we can find
here and you know I was one of those
people and it was um
it was interesting we would have it on
the radar we would have it on then the
full year system that IR system
and all that's getting pumped into our
visor and tracked to our eyeballs and
telling us exactly where to look and we
do this type of merging exercise quite
often where we fly up to something we
assess its characteristics its weapons
load out and we begin a dog fight with
it
um in this case we would come up to that
merge and all our sensors would show us
where to look but then we couldn't see
the objects we turned back around and
they would still be there on the radar
and on the flear
and that was kind of a status quo for a
while until we almost hit one of the
objects at the entrance to our working
areas two aircraft from my Squadron were
entering the working areas
um side by side and at a very particular
altitude and GPS location is where we
enter those working areas and one of
these objects went right between the two
aircraft and the lead aircraft was able
to actually gain tally of it and he
described it as a black Cube inside of a
clear sphere
about five to fifteen feet in diameter
when you say gain tally of it he
actually saw it with his own eyes
correct with his own eyeballs and to my
knowledge that was the first time we had
seen one of these objects with their own
eyes it was a Black Cube within a clear
sphere
and the tips of the cube best we could
assess at that point were touching the
inside of that clear sphere so you're
probably
friends with the other Pilots when when
you got back and you were saying hey
what did you see and he described this
you guys must have been eager to hear
more or flipping out or something along
those lines
we were moving along a progression right
we went from radar errors to something
physical but not knowing what they were
but when we saw it physically like that
our first thought you know we were never
all about UFOs or or uaps as they're
called now that really never entered
into our conscience other than something
to laugh at
um so we always thought there was a very
pragmatic explanation if we just had
enough information
um and at this point when we physically
saw it like I said as that Cube we
assumed that some this must have been
some kind of strange classified program
or drone program that must have gotten
too big for its bridges and essentially
has been operating in a place that they
should have been perhaps by accident
perhaps not but either way something had
to be done and due to the nature of this
near mid-air uh I mean we were obligated
to file a Aviation safety report due to
the close proximity and that's what we
did uh we started filing them within the
aviation safety hazard reporting system
and that was again status quo for the
time being we essentially just disarmed
them we tried to avoid them if they were
in our working areas which they're out
there pretty much every day in some
capacity we would just you know Flex to
a different area and do our best to
avoid them what what years uh were were
this and
um what part of the world
yeah so this is right off the coast of
uh Virginia Beach Virginia and this was
in the 2014 to 2015 time frame you so
you follow the report but it sounds like
it's pretty much common knowledge among
Pilots that hey there are these things
out there they're gonna hit your radar
in a particular way
um they seem like actual objects like if
you get close your instruments I'll
start saying hey the thing's there and
you want to try and avoid them because
if you hit one no one knows what happens
we would assume it would be I mean
catastrophic to the aircraft I mean
based off of what we are seeing uh
there's no question in our mind that you
know this would result in loss of
aircraft like if we hit anything of that
size out there
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
I have always been someone who thought
spending a little extra on your mattress
is a wise investment because you spend
let's say a 30-year life on it it makes
you healthier more energized maybe there
are even other people that enjoy your
mattress too whether it's kids or that
extra special someone Helix sleep is the
mattress company we recommend it
includes 14 unique mattresses you can
have a personalized mattress ship
straight to your door free of charge and
they are so confident they will give you
a hundred night trial yep you can sleep
on it for three months after you take
that Helix sleep quiz figure out the
best mattress for you sent straight to
your door don't trust me alone my kids
also can't get enough of this mattress
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long song with Helix better sleep
starts now
[Music]
foreign
for a second so you're zooming in from
New Hampshire uh did you grow up in the
New England area I did I grew up in
central Massachusetts and when did you
know you wanted to be a fighter pilot I
knew I wanted to do that after my junior
year in college I was doing a mechanical
engineering fire protection engineering
five-year program and I did an
internship after my junior year and I
said I'm not going to like this for the
rest of my life and you know it kind of
drove me to say hey reassess what was
valuable to me and what was important to
me and you know how I want to live my
life at least in the short term and
um on the drive back home because I did
that in Atlanta so on the drive back up
to Massachusetts I I thought about you
know what was kind of the polar opposite
of this what was the thing that would
you know motivate me and encourage me
regardless of you know the semantics of
how difficult it was to be and I thought
flying Fighters would be an incredible
Challenge and would have incredible
opportunities whether I you know was
completely successful or not wow so the
time you made that decision and then uh
heading towards the Navy how many years
was it before you wind up flying uh
fighter jet yeah so I actually on the
drive home I also elected to change my
major to aerospace engineering because I
thought that would be better for my
application doubled up on all my courses
in my senior year so I could finish with
the degree on time uh and then I was
accepted as a pilot to the Navy uh
probably about
14 months after I made that decision wow
in that meantime I also went and got
private flight training myself I paid
paid for about 30 hours of flight time
to see you know make sure I liked it and
sure I wasn't gonna get sick as soon as
I got wheels up and just kind of
explored it best I could beforehand and
so I came in you know I threw myself all
the way in to try to get that slot and I
applied just as a pilot because I knew
that's what I wanted to do
um and I was fortunate enough to get in
so back to then 2014 2015 you're you're
seeing uh these unidentified aerial
phenomena you submit a report saying hey
we almost ran into one of these is there
any follow-up to that report or like did
do you get uh feedback
so those reporting mechanisms within uh
always just be for Naval Aviation safety
they're not Proactive or preventative
reporting mechanisms for the vast
majority of it it's more for Data
Tracking purposes over time
and so we weren't really expecting
anything back but no there was nothing
back
um it was just status quo like you know
we were avoiding them and that was that
in 2015
early 2015 we're getting ready to leave
on a deployment
uh aboard a USS Theodore Roosevelt and
we began our workup training which is a
pretty intensive six-month uh training
program we go through that involves us
living on the boat for a month and a
half or so at a time and doing you know
training training like we would fight
overseas essentially off the aircraft
carrier
and so we were still experiencing these
objects and we went down to off the
coast of Jacksonville Florida in 2015.
uh operating off the USS Theodore
Roosevelt and we had those objects were
down there when we got down there
additionally we also recorded additional
objects and those are the videos that
have been publicly released by the
Department of Defense the Gimbal and the
go fast video
it was at that time period when we
recorded those objects which were unique
to us wow
um so uh I saw the news accounts of
those recordings and I suppose I will
fast forward to present day a little bit
so but so before we started this
interview I looked up how Americans
think and feel about the possibility of
uh life
uh on other planets uh what they think
about UFOs or uaps and it seems like the
polling has it at something like
two-thirds of Americans think that
there's probably life somewhere out
there
um and I I will say that I personally
fall into that camp uh just if I think
about the vastness of space and uh
almost infinite number of planets and
then the extended time period it seems
highly unlikely that we would be the
only
planet that this vastness that actually
developed any form of an intelligent
life uh and then there's a smaller
percentage who think that
UFOs and uaps are actually evidence of
uh extraterrestrial life it's still very
significant uh it's something like 40 to
50 percent uh think that it's probably
tied into
extraterrestrial life I have a feeling
that both of those numbers have probably
gone up in the last three months
because
there's just been a whole lot in the
news recently uh and you're now actually
I'd say one of the preeminent voices on
this because you've started this very
benignly named organization which I
appreciated a great deal like Americans
were safer Aerospace
I'm dead to try to shed some light
um uh on this so let's just briefly
discuss the recent news accounts
um so uaps and UFOs have been all over
the news over this last number of weeks
uh there is this Chinese spy balloon uh
story but then it seems like the story
is much bigger than that yeah absolutely
so we had a series of events that just
kind of kicked off and it kicked off as
you said with a very clear imagery of a
Chinese by balloon or at least a a
balloon with some payload uh below it
that was identified as originating
from China likely for intelligence
gathering purposes
shortly after that over the course of
the weekend three other objects were
shot down in various areas across North
America and what was communicated uh was
a pretty clear bifurcation that that
Chinese spyballoon in the other three
objects were very distinct categories
there was the Chinese five balloon and
the other three objects which are
currently unidentified and also the
search for the remains of the objects
have been called off as well
um so they're a bit of a mystery why did
we find these objects you know overhead
well it's what's been publicly
communicated is that we essentially back
down the speed filters on our defensive
radar systems and you know just very
basically how these systems work is that
they receive information that
information is cataloged according to
various parameters perhaps AirSpeed
being one of them
and then that information is sent to the
proper uh processing agency
so what's that means things that look
like missiles go one place and things
that you know look like uh something
else go somewhere else
but I don't know if we were looking for
very slow speed objects and once we we
brought those filters down we started
noticing other objects over our airspace
that again as of this point are not
identified
now this all just occurred very recently
however it's very reminiscent of the
conversation I've been having
um since about uh 2019 or so about uh
low or no speed objects operating off
the Eastern Seaboard uh potentially
categorized as intelligence gathering
platforms or potentially else based off
of their uh performance but regardless
of what those three objects are and I'm
not claiming they are the same objects
or they are not we don't know but
regardless we're not as certain about
what's above our heads as uh as we
thought we were and that's very clear
now we need to open up the aperture on
what's above our airspace and not
confuse the fact that seeing things
drift along in the wind that a
potentially adversarial spy programs not
to say everything that is going to fall
into that same bucket that we're seeing
because what we're seeing are things
that have you know more interesting more
challenging uh behaviors to them that
don't fit in those you know those
balloon-like entity buckets and that's
not me saying that that's the Department
of Defense and the odni saying that
through their UAP reports
foreign
tour is coming to a city near you that
means I'm coming to a city near you I'm
heading to San Francisco Los Angeles
Seattle Raleigh Denver and more in the
spring go to fordparty.com to check out
the upcoming dates or just check out my
social media primarily Twitter
unfortunately see you soon
so it seems like if you retrace the
mythology around these beliefs there was
a point uh earlier when
I think it was
um a really suspicious International
environment there's like a cold war and
Espionage
um uh and so there is like this sense
that there were a lot of Secrets out
there
and and uh and you also had a sense at
that time that
um if someone were to events something
like uh beliefs in in UFOs then it truly
would be politically self-destructive or
professionally self-destructive and and
I feel like times might have shifted
since then because uh like that there's
almost like a greater openness to the
fact that we might not know something or
that institutions might not be playing
it straight like what do you think about
the direction of American
culture and the fact that now I think
that we'd be open to things that uh in
the day we wouldn't have been yeah I
think you're absolutely right I mean
during the cold Wars it very much uh
fearful Society both internally where I
think there was distrust between the
branches and fear of Soviets you know
internal spies in the government as well
as you know obviously a lot of
international distrust uh and and
fighting
um so there there was you know my
understanding is that even more not even
more so but in addition to that there
was also a fear that due to the high
amount of UAP reporting or UFO Reporting
that it was actually going to be
something that the Soviets could take
advantage of by putting air assets into
our airspace under the cover of uh UFO
clutter and get caught up in in too much
reporting and so one of the
methodologies that was undertaken was to
diminish and push down the reporting so
that the systems weren't overwhelmed
with anomalous objects and that you know
airplanes and air threats could be
identified but you know that's a little
historical context but you know what we
see today is society has adapted with
our new tools and our technology and our
ways of communicating I feel like we're
much more adaptable and flexible the
changes in our society we're also much
more open to new ideas and pushing past
those kind of historical boundaries and
that's really I think what makes us
exceptional and that's what's going to
move the conversation forward and why I
think it hasn't just gone away because
once we were at a point in our society
where we can latch on to an idea like
this and it's it's a powerful motivator
and people are really passionate about
these ideas and with the tools to
communicate you can't just shut that
conversation down anymore and so I I see
this as a conversation that's going to
continue to grow for that reason because
people can find people with similar
interest and that's that's what's
happening so you obviously have the most
direct experience with uh the Eastern
Seaboard here in America uh the Navy the
dod is this something that's happening
worldwide to the extent that you have
exposure to pilots in other parts of the
world
certainly from from my understanding
historically this conversation goes back
you know let's just say since the 50s or
60s there's been reports uh
internationally of events occurring not
just from civilians but from military
and commercial pilots as well
uh I don't think that there's a complete
enough picture on that and there's some
natural boundaries about what we want to
share with our International partners
and how we do that you know especially
in the Modern Age here but I think going
forward the way we really
bring this conversation to something of
conclusion if that even can be done is
to really engage with the International
Community on this topic and say hey we
invite you all to you know help us
figure this out because I don't think uh
America or one group within the United
States uh really has the authority to
speak for the entire world to say it's
none of you and it must be this so I
think we really need to bring in the
International Community and look at this
as a globe and see where we can draw
conclusions in yeah it could be a real
opportunity for some kind of global I
would hesitate to say Unity but at least
uh cooperation
so when it comes to explaining these
phenomena
um the most common explanations are
equipment malfunction which at this
point I think you can rule out given the
ubiquity because you know it's like
happened over and over again uh foreign
military domestic military something
civilian or extraterrestrial are those
like the the four major categories
mostly I would say instead of
extraterrestrial I would just throw it
in the other bucket uh because it starts
we start to you know bacon some
assumptions if we look at things
extraterrestrial and the fact is we have
something anomalous but we don't know
what it is people ask me all the time
you know what what do you think it is
you know yeah what is it really and
we're just not there we're not at a
point where we can necessarily draw
conclusions on it now you you've you've
said it could be ours it could be
someone else's on this planet or or it
could be something else that we haven't
identified that is either from here from
somewhere else but we have to continue
to gather data about that before we can
draw those conclusions we've had baked
in assumptions in this conversation for
so long even with the name UFO flying
objects we've identified or we've
updated the terms in the last National
Defense authorization Act of 2023 uh to
have unidentified anomalous phenomenon
because we have identified there there
is an anomaly there we don't know if
they're flying or if they're you know in
space or what domain but we truly do
have that mystery and we need to get to
the bottom of it yeah some of the
descriptions you have about them
just being still even though there are
gale force winds around them in a way
that would be very very difficult I mean
it does seem truly anomalous and doesn't
like doesn't seem like they're yeah
they're like obeying the laws of physics
sometimes they said these other at least
that's the sense I get it's confusing
you know it they operate in a way that
we're not expecting to see so at first
it's almost like well this must be some
kind of software or something of that
nature but when you realize it
corresponds to reality
um it it breaks your brain a little bit
foreign
we are living in the era of big Tech AI
chat GPT generative tools and these big
tech companies have made it a habit to
pick up everything we are doing online
why should they get our data and where
left out in the cold it's reasons like
this that I use expressvpn to hide my
unique IP address to make it harder for
big Tech to track me and my identity and
activity and encrypt all of my online
comings and goings and it's not like you
have to be a tech whiz to use expressvpn
literally just tap one button on your
phone or computer to activate it you
don't want your family to be vulnerable
and one subscription to expressvpn
covers me my wife and my kids on up to
five devices so stop letting big Tech
leech on your data freely use my link
expressvpn.com yang right now and you
can get three extra months free that's
exp r e s s vpn.com Yang to get
protected with a VPN rated number one by
CNET tech radar and most importantly me
expressvpn.com yang
foreign
out there defending the country uh in
2015 2016.
um uh and uh you eventually stepped away
uh from the service uh and went into
Private Industry what year was that so I
left the Navy officially in uh 2019
and I did have an I left uh the F-18 a
little bit before that I went to
Meridian Mississippi as an instructor
pilot uh training students before they
got to the F-18 and from there I
departed in 2019. so so you really were
like uh like you know one of those
flight instructors did you did you scare
everyone did you talk about uh I mean
I'm not talking about Europe friends
generally did you do like the drill
sergeant routine
no it's you know it's not like that it
used to be like that I'm actually
remember being pulled out of a uh flight
simulator to do push-ups at one point
because something was screwed up uh but
you know I think modern times we
understand those aren't the best uh
teaching mechanisms especially when
we're dealing with putting people into
extremely highly stressful environments
for the first time sometimes and so uh
it's it's a real process and a real art
to be able to give you know these
students enough rope to hang themselves
but snatch it away at the last moment as
well because that's unfortunately one of
the best ways to learn sometimes but I
did that for about three and a half
years uh in Mississippi
and it's really the reason I I think I
ended up speaking out about this as I
was getting out because you know the
Navy's trained me as an aviation safety
officer so they actually sent me down to
Pensacola Florida for five weeks to not
just prevent mishaps from occurring in
my Squadron and to ensure safety
standards are met but should the worst
happen actually go out in the field pick
the pieces up and figure out what what
happened and unfortunately I had to do
that a couple times but I was sitting in
the ready room in 2017 when I saw the
New York Times article come out with the
the gimbal video in it and when I saw
that I said you know oh my gosh I was
there that was the video you know I saw
that that was my buddy's voices you know
um so it was like holy smokes but then I
was like oh my gosh like I wonder if
this was still happening so I reached
back to a lot of folks that were still
flying on the east coast and they're
like yes this is still happening you
know I left for my we left for a
deployment I left that deployment to go
become an instructor so I never went
back to the east coast
um but some of my friends were and I
called them up and like yeah of course
it's still happening we have broad
notice to Airmen in the local region
just to alert Pilots that this is
happening because we have no solution
for this and so that was a state of
affairs it was the best we could do
um and that's when I realized that this
wasn't going to get resolved from the
current internal channels and that's
when I you know made the internal
decision
to try to you know help where I could in
this and whatever really means I could
because it was just a matter of time in
my perspective that we had a mid-air uh
every other situation that we have
somewhat similar to this we would try to
mitigate that factor the best we could
but for some reason this one case it was
just something that we did not want to
look at as a problem we had no reporting
mechanisms we had you know no one paying
attention to it it was something we
couldn't even talk about you know
without laughing really and it was just
a matter of time until we lost assets
and lives
well uh it's clear that you took your
responsibility very seriously I mean you
were literally teaching the next
generation of pilots and you're thinking
to yourself wait a minute like you know
if this isn't resolved one of these
Pilots could end up losing their lives
because they have a collision uh with
one of these things because we're not
properly documenting or accounting for
them and once we started documenting
them uh we had 144 reports as of the
first reporting by the UAP task force
and in that report there were 11 near
midairs so that was 11 opportunities to
lose at least one aircraft and perhaps
two lives in that mishap and was that
reporting done uh by the Department of
Defense correct that was done by the U.S
Navy and technically the report time
frame spans from 2004 until I believe
2019 or late 2018 whenever they cut off
but the vast majority of those cases are
from uh 2018 onwards when the U.S Navy
started their official reporting program
per reasonable to me I mean even if we
don't know what these things are we
should be transparent by what we do know
which is hey there are these things and
uh we we don't want to lose a plane or a
pilot so you know we should start being
frank about it
um the way we are anything else that a
pilot might run into and we see this
problem even more so on the commercial
side on the military side we have all
the sensors and tools to give us more
information but often the results of
that is classifying things of that
nature on the commercial side they don't
have those tools but what they do have
their eyeballs and they have a lot of
time looking out and occasionally when
they do see things they are discouraged
from reporting it they fear losing their
medical certificate which is not just
your job but your career wow and no one
wants to restart their career in their
40s
um so you know there's a lot of problems
and things preventing commercial uh air
crew from from feeling comfortable
talking about this and so I've done a
few things to try to help that first
I've created the merge podcast which is
a platform for Pilots to come and have a
conversation with me pilot the pilot uh
that you know we're not gonna try to
draw conclusions or you know break down
their experience in any great detail but
just to open it up and share what their
experiences are on a trusted platform
where the X-Files music isn't going to
be playing in the background and they
don't have to fear losing their medical
certificate because they're being
embarrassed on national TV or something
uh and we've been seeing great success
from that additionally with the American
Institute of Aeronautics and
astronautics I've helped them stand up
in integration Outreach committee on
unidentified anomalous phenomenon and so
we have engineering efforts there under
that bucket that is working on our
detection characterization and
evaluation methodology so that we can
inform uh the policy and procedure
makers that we've brought together under
that under that committee to advise the
airline to advise the FAA to advise our
federal government on what the correct
reporting procedure should be what the
correct safety procedures should be and
how we're going to learn more
information about this and then on the
last side the Americans for safe
Aerospace I've recently founded this
issue Focus advocacy group to really
attack the uh the issue where the most
work can be done which is on Capitol
Hill and so we're going to be pushing to
push for policy and legislation to
ensure that those commercial pilots do
have the ability to come forward and
talk about this and they don't fear
losing their careers we want to make
sure that we just learned that Arrow you
know hasn't been funded this whole time
why are they you know why are senators
and Congress people signing up now to
fund that office right we want to ensure
these mechanisms are working correctly
and we don't have to have shoot Downs
over U.S airspace to get this
conversation going
I like it a lot uh if someone wants to
be helpful to you or keep up with your
work or be supportive or let their
Congressman know it's like look
um it we should be mainstreaming the
fact that uh we don't know everything
but we know that there's something up
and uh we're not getting great
information because everyone uh thinks
it's going to be professionally super
detrimental to say what they saw how can
the average American help you in your
work
the best way they can help right now is
go to
safeaerospace.org and sign up for
further updates that's going to be the
best vehicle for the average American to
be able to stay informed on this topic
to stay educated on this topic and to
learn how they can help and push this
topic with their elected representatives
well I I think this is such a
fascinating topic I mean at this point
we have to know that just having the
ability to speak openly and plainly
would be a massive uh
Improvement I would say uh full credit
to you for taking the steps you've taken
it's very courageous and I sense it's
very selfless and patriotic on your part
I'm talking to you I think just about
anyone who spent uh the the last half an
hour listening would regard you as just
a like a completely objective
principled uh
intellectually honest human and someone
who spent thousands of hours risking
your life uh in the air for our greater
good so uh really just kudos to you for
being
um so honest and patriotic and I
instinctively feel like what you're
doing is going to end up uh opening us
up to different possibilities and uh
wind up being on the right side of
History I appreciate you saying all that
Andrew the end of the day for me this is
very simple it's either a national
security Aviation safety issue and we
need to deal with that with the
mechanisms we have or it's something
else and we need to have the scientific
integrity and The Bravery to go look at
it and explore it regardless of the
results bravery and integrity uh I again
mean I sense that those are the kinds of
things that guide you and your decision
making and I I think that we could all
take a lot from it uh Ryan I can't wait
for us to do this again after we know
some more
um well congrats to you you're on social
media feel free to follow Ryan
um on his accounts and also check out
Americans for a safer Aerospace uh did
you come up with that name yourself
it was a team effort it was a team
effort
because I I have to say like I could see
the possibility what were the alts well
like what did you consider and uh
disregard
um we didn't we didn't get too creative
with the names we stayed pretty
mainstream um but we we really wanted to
make sure that people understood that
um this isn't a fear-based discussion
that we don't want people to feel unsafe
now but there's just so much room for
curiosity here and it's just gonna make
us all stronger as a country and as a
people you know I I was chatting about
this uh with my wife
um and we concluded that any
civilization that could project its
technology this far afield uh if it
winds up being sourced from you know
another planet
um is so far ahead of us that
um that you'd imagine they're probably
benign because they're just so uh
elevated I mean obviously you know like
you have to be careful about crashing
into one of their things if that's what
it turns out it is but I I think that
kind of curiosity like I I actually find
it kind of uplifting myself I agree with
you I think it's a hopeful conversation
I don't think this is something that we
should fear or be hesitant about I I
take the tact that if something has
perhaps taken the gained the ability to
travel across the stars and has been
able to achieve such Monumental things
that they would have been able to solve
their own differences by that point
yeah and maybe that can be something we
can all strive to emulate God knows we
need it
out of you and hopefully we'll have a
chance to meet in person my pleasure
Andrew I'm looking forward to it cheers
[Music]